tu deviens quoi toi Cindy ben écoute là
je suis en train de faire une une expo
de peinture préparé une expo de peinture
très particulière que je vous montrerai
tout à l'heure c'est une exclusivité
pour toi Cyril c'est des bailles chelous
mais tout à fait artistique non c'est
vrai ou pas
je suis le pinceau ah ouais est-ce que
vous voulez que je vous montre parce que
vous avez l'air je suis le pinceau
vous vous peignez avec votre corps
on n'arrive pas à s'imaginer vous voulez
pas que je vous montre parce que là vous
ils sont en train de se poser des
questions bizarres vous pouvez vous
montrer comment vous payez vous allez
non je vais vous montrer mes toiles
parce que je me suis dit
[Applaudissements]
on va pas regarder ce que fait Cindy
après on parlera de Secret Story j'ai
envie de voir on a envie de voir là nous
a chauffé s'il vous plaît on peut voir
là c'est où tu as donné la régie
moi
déjà quand
je vous laisse deviner
c'est par là où passe le sable du temps
entre nos cuisses très chers
c'est quoi et vous avez fait comment
pour le mettre ah ça c'est un procédé
aussi que c'est pas mal je trouve que
voilà cette exposition s'appelle
cocofesse et savez-vous ce que c'est que
le coco-fesse irène
est un la graine la plus grosse du monde
et elle représente un peu le pharmacien
je sais pas si c'est réactif chez vous
du monde et en fait la femme est matrice
de l'humain en fait de l'humanité et en
fait
cette histoire là bah écoutez j'ai pas
encore établi les prix la prochaine expo
serait en octobre ah bah ça ça va être
dans les 3100 je suis là oh celui-là je
vous ferai un prix Cyril
vous peignez au public parfois vous
peignez en public je ferai peut-être je
ferai peut-être un petit happening pour
ma prochaine expo dans le 15e
arrondissement
c'est très sympa c'est original moi
j'adore tout ce qui est original tu sais
c'est pour ça qu'il y a que des gens que
j'avais pas compris à la base ici
Cindy on se rappelle tu as participé à
la saison 3 de l'émission Secret Story
c'est en 2009 on va regarder tout de
suite ton portrait de l'époque tu es
marié
c'est pareil Castaldi
jamais vraiment marié
c'était ton style Benjamin cette fête
ton style oui c'était mon style vagin et
c'est toujours ça l'est toujours il m'a
un peu agacé donc non c'est vrai
plutôt délire
comme on dit dans le jargon les Aigles
sont des ex quand on voit la gueule du
vomi en plus
[Musique]
la vérité la vérité mais regarde-moi ce
que tu veux
toutes ces années je me suis dit
j'avais envie de revoir mon petit Benji
d'amour
[Musique]
faut pour toute il ne sait absolument
rien passé de sexuels
tu participes à la saison 3 on l'a vu
hein ton portrait et le moins qu'on
puisse dire c'est que tu as marqué le
programme il y a deux choses qu'on leur
retient particulièrement chez toi la
première c'est que tu as un sacré
caractère c'est bon ça comme lancement
et la seconde c'est qu'on rigole pas
avec le lait d'annexe non c'est sûr
c'est vraiment ça on peut pas rigoler
avec ça regardez
si je veux quelque chose je l'ai tout de
suite ou jamais j'avais trop envie de me
mettre de la crème au lait d'ânesse
c'est qui qui a
pris la crème il est mort il a
plus d'après mes affaires oui je suis
capricieux
le son jeune des autres habitants me
dérange
la table mais comment je vais faire pour
dormir alors qu'il y a de la lumière
ils ont pas dehors
Secret Story il est 19h50 on est en
direct de revenir très très vite sur une
plateforme aussi Secret Story c'est vrai
qu'il y avait Cindy moi c'était ma
préférée Cindy c'est la seule vraiment
que je retiens de Secret Story est-ce
qu'il y a des séquences que tu regrettes
non il y a aucune séquence que je
regrette je me suis bien amusé dans ce
jeu parce que pour moi c'est un jeu et
voilà je me suis bien amusé j'ai adoré
embêter mes camarades voilà c'était cool
j'ai jamais pris ça au sérieux tout
comme la célébrité j'ai jamais pris ça
au sérieux donc voilà alors on va voir
la première saison de Secret Story ça
date de 2007 et attention c'est encore
une émission présentée par Benjamin
Castaldi c'était partout et alors
c'était sur TF1 c'était pas très M6
exactement c'était en deuxième partie de
soirée ou non on a commencé
vous êtes parti en deuxième partie après
Koh-Lanta c'est ça l'enchaînement mais
pour répondre à la question est-ce que
les secrets vous y croyez moi quand on
m'a dit tu vas refaire le donc c'est
crête je pensais que c'était un twist
pour refaire le loft et je croyais pas
du tout au secret c'était un peu comme
vous et en fait les secrets
contrairement à ce que vous n'aimez pas
c'est quoi déjà c'est quoi le secret de
Cindy elle était pas en couple avec
quelqu'un ou avec
non mais je veux dire bon sexuel
Aurore aime beaucoup Cindy elle m'a
envoyé un texto elle m'a dit vraiment
c'était marqué ta nouvelle femme n'était
pas encore ta femme à l'époque non qui
avait cassé Cindy mais c'est un peu les
mêmes jours de température
je te sens pas comment
un peu s'il te plaît
calme-toi un peu je vois que c'est pas
bien si tu veux aller faire pipi comment
et moi tu peux y aller alors on va
revoir ça regardez c'était la première
de Secret Story c'était en 2007 et
castaliste il y a 16 ans 16 ans et vous
n'avez pas changé Benjamin non mais
c'est vrai
que je vous dise vos yeux se sont
ouverts
[Applaudissements]
ça y est ça y est c'est ce soir c'est
maintenant le lancement de l'élément TF1
Secret Story
après toutes les plus forts rumeurs
entendues élus vous serez toute la
vérité rien que la vérité ce soir je
vous le jure vous connaîtrez enfin les
13 candidats SyFy cette garçons qui vont
vivre dans une maison de 900 m² et
surveiller 22h sur 24 par 50 caméras et
autant de micro
on va faire pleurer Casta sur ma vie
incroyables
c'est des grosses machines comme on dit
stressé ou pas énormément quoi
dans les 30 dernières secondes je
courais après une mission pendant deux
heures c'est horrible
mais moi j'adore moi je trouve très beau
là il est très bon aussi très bon il y a
du monde il y a du monde franchement
il y a eu de nombreuses histoires
d'amour qui sont créées mon dérision de
retenir qu'une c'était celle d'Amélie et
Sénart vous rappelez ou pas la quatrième
saison regardez on a même plus assister
à leur demande en mariage c'était fou ça
dans Secret Story
je crois que
il est temps pour moi que je vienne un
homme ton homme j'espère
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
que
[Musique]
ça c'est ça que je fais
allez alors ils sont vraiment mariés ou
pas
il y a un timing à respecter il y a un
emploi
sont plus réels que ça quoi
[Applaudissements]
il y avait beaucoup de Mythos parce que
Secret Story reste de venir redevenir de
revenir à ce qu'il y avait beaucoup de
mythologie il paraît qu'il y avait des
gens vous donnez les secrets genre toi
voilà non il y avait des secrets qui
étaient mécanisés puisque c'est à dire
c'est en fait il y avait des quand on a
un très bon casting si on a quelqu'un
qu'on veut absolument avoir dans le
programme et on a pas de secret pas un
gros secret on lui inventé un secret
genre bien sûr
c'est exactement ce que je veux dire un
secret ton père a trois couilles avant
l'inventer un secret assez rare aussi
non mais non mais on inventé des secrets
mécanisés de rentrer avec avec son sa
sœur mais des mécaniques mais des faux
secret honnêtement je ne crois pas voilà
c'est vrai elle a été vérifiée par
Aurore
il a été
demain
j'avais pas fait la tête pour toi
non mais attendez je vais à la
maternelle vous me faites venir vous
m'appelez 17h pour être là à 17h45 enfin
je veux dire si tout le monde se met à
chialer à moindre chose
[Applaudissements]
s'il te plaît parce que là tu vois non
non parce que regarde tu avais euh tu
étais chez Jordan Deluxe toi tu sais le
gars avec le nœud papillon
alors déjà il y a un moment tu étais pas
en super bon terme avec Benjamin
ce qu'il a dit je suis Jordan de luxe
donc
[Rires]
c'est en fait mais je sais pas sur tous
les prime tous les jours vous n'êtes pas
un petit peu fait des films
et en fait à la sortie de l'émission et
en fait moi je vous dis sincèrement ce
qui m'a énervé en fait c'est qu'en fait
tu pensais
je sais pas comment dire mais de me
mettre de considérer de façon inférieure
de de me rabaisser par rapport à sa
nanargue de l'époque qui n'est même pas
resté d'ailleurs ça m'a un peu tu vois
avec cette époque de passer derrière tu
vois d'être la nana de cachette devant
me cacher pour pas nuire tu vois
l'intégrité de cette nana qui était
inexistante perdue dans le game ça m'a
vexé voilà pourquoi je rentre dans la
gueule tous les jours
c'est quoi le bail j'ai pas compris vous
avez pas compris
avec Benjamin mais moi je pouvais pas
aller dîner avec un mec entre guillemets
qui était enfin en cachette enfin je
veux dire moi je suis pas une nana
charisme qui est quelqu'un quoi je veux
dire pourquoi pas enfin non d'ailleurs
c'est non d'office mais je veux dire là
je me sentais un peu vexé c'est que
rabaissé par quelqu'un qui est plus bas
que moi je ne peux pas sauf que moi je
ne compte sur des repas du tout
inférieur à qui que ce soit mais donc
dîner avec lui mais en secret c'est ça
c'était le thème de l'émission
donc tu
vas tu as dit
non et après on a fait une émission de
télé un pilote avec Carole Rousseau dont
tu étais l'invité donc tu es amnésique
mais tu te souviens pas
Carole Rousseau tu étais l'invité de
l'émission de Benjamin et moi sur le
plateau il avait été encore un peu
infecte super hautain et rabaissant oui
franchement Benjamin tu es un peu comme
ça je suis désolé
mais moi je suis pas fâché voilà c'est
dit c'est dit on en parle plus
mais rien du tout elle faisait un
casting fallait bien qu'elle me trouve
un secret ah oui donc elle a attaqué le
terrain c'est tout
le terrain
vocalement je vais discutant bah elle
est Castle il faut bien qu'elle sache
que la salle de Benjamin et vous vous
êtes tartiner le feuillus
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme une enquêtrice ça fait un
casting j'ai pas de secret veux savoir
quel secret peut me donner pour que je
rentre dans l'émission forcément
un peu dragouiller pour le jeu quoi
ça aurait été plus simple
[Rires]
parce que vous avez parlé d'Aurore la
femme de Benjamin chez Jordan Deluxe
regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les grosses poitrines
[Rires]
cette histoire ah oui c'est fou
j'imagine que c'était Aurore que
Benjamin tu avais invité à dîner que tu
avais dit non je t'avais dragué
après de ne pas avoir une aventure avec
Benjamin Castaldi pour réussir il aurait
peut-être fallu que je sais pas je sois
plus conciliant
[Musique]
la copine de Guillaume ça tu l'as dit
aussi
parce que Guillaume là c'est amusé à le
dire et que à un moment donné tous ses
copains venaient me voir pour voilà me
répéter ce qui m'avait dit donc je me
suis dit allez hop vous êtes resté
combien de temps Guillaume et toi
ensemble je sais plus on s'est vu
quelquefois plusieurs fois quoi mais
c'était pas pour moi c'était vraiment un
couple quoi
j'ai plus l'habitude ça va autant encore
il était jeune on était jeune voilà mais
vous avez fait plus avec Guillaume ou
avec Aurore
[Applaudissements]
voilà c'est un vrai une vraie aventure
pour de vrai
non je trouvais sympa c'était il y a
longtemps il y a quelques années deux en
trois ans
ouais au moins ouais
sur les dates
quoi donc Cindy elle a eu un aventure
avec Guillaume une aventure avec la
femme de Casta parce qu'on a eu la
confirmation ça c'est galoche on sait
que ça c'est galoche
quand on discute on a besoin
on a du mal à discuter
maintenant voilà chacun voit sa porte
bah non mais c'est bon mais t'es pas la
photo de la meuf de cascade
non et on va aller et ah oui c'est vrai
qu'il la connaît
alors
Jean-Michel maire de TPMP et bah tu vois
comme les choses sont bien faites et
voilà non mais c'est la chance c'est
vrai ça c'est vrai
c'est toi qui l'a dit ouais
c'est toi qui l'as dit non je pense que
c'était pour déconner est-ce que je peux
tout balancer ou pas c'est pas drôle
[Rires]
c'était juste pour faire une blague à
Jean-Michel
parce que j'ai cru
ah ça peut s'arranger Jean-Mi
tu es toujours maquille toi bien sûr
[Rires]
et le plus classe le plus mignon le plus
sympa
à l'époque je sais pas s'il était ou pas
mais bon moi je parle pas de Casta non
plus vraiment aussi il est très classe
[Applaudissements]
moi je suis de la merde
dans le mille non j'aime pas ça
la personnalité
quand je te dis dans le mille c'est dans
le caractère qu'il aime non non non
[Applaudissements]
non
excuse-moi c'est Sephora ou c'est
vraiment qui parle c'est Mario le gars
c'est un truc de fou
tu es célibataire en ce moment
oui ça a été bon
[Musique]
je suis pas très branché couple tu vois
je suis très bien
est-ce que tu pourrais
dîner avec Raymond
je pense pas qu'il est marié donc non
alors
moi je t'ai dit franchement bravo
s'il était pas marié on est dans un
monde idyllique dans une fixe
pourquoi pas un dîner c'est un langage à
rien alors
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
toutes les deux semaines on sait pas où